le mercredi qui ne se déroule pas à
l'horaire habituel mais à défaut de nous
réunir à l'heure du déjeuner nous nous
réunissons à l'heure du dîner je vous
remercie pour votre assiduité et votre
présence pour ces échanges
nous avons échangé à l'occasion du
conseil des ministres largement sur la
situation sanitaire
nous sommes entrés dans une quatrième
vague du virus si nous partons d'un
faible nombre de contaminations la
dynamique de l'épidémie est extrêmement
forte
nous constatons une vague plus rapide
une pente plus raide que toutes les
précédentes
nous devons tout mettre en oeuvre dès
maintenant pour que cette vague ne soit
pas aussi plus dévastatrices nous
partons de bas mais cette vague peut
monter très vite et elle peut monter
très haut
le taux d'incidence poursuit son
explosion dans notre pays il atteint
désormais 86 pour cent mille habitants
au niveau national selon les chiffres
corrigés du jour férié du 14 juillet
soit une augmentation de près de 125 %
en une semaine une hausse de ce type
je le dis aussi forte aussi soudaine
nous n'en avions jamais connue depuis le
début de l'épidémie dans notre pays le
nombre de nouveaux cas détectés a doublé
en une semaine et depuis plusieurs jours
nous avons franchi à nouveau le seuil
des 10000 cas positifs
chaque jour le taux de reproduction du
virus c'est-à-dire le nombre de
personnes pouvant être contaminés par
une personne malade monte lui aussi en
flèche et atteint un niveau record face
à un virus qui contamine à la vitesse de
l'éclair
tout laisse à penser que ce taux devrait
continuer à augmenter
localement le variant delta qui compte
ce qui concerne aujourd'hui 80% des
contaminations dans notre pays n'épargne
aucun territoire alors que seize
départements avaient un taux d'incidence
supérieur aux soldats et aux seuils
d'alerté
vendredi ils sont ce soir trois jours
plus tard à peine largement plus du
double 39 départements avaient ainsi
dépassé le seuil d alerte notamment les
départements du littoral
la dynamique est particulièrement
marquée en corse avec une hausse de
l'incidence de plus de 700 % en
occitanie avec une hausse de 170% en
région sud avec une augmentation de
l'incidence de 130 % dans certains
territoires une situation qui était déjà
très préoccupante continue de s'aggraver
dans les pyrénées-orientales
taux d'incidence s'élève désormais à
trois cent quarante cinq pour cent mille
habitants ces 25 fois plus qu'au début
du mois
la situation est par ailleurs
extrêmement inquiétante en martinique
face à cette véritable explosion des cas
le préfet dans les pyrénées-orientales a
pris avec l'accord du gouvernement les
décisions qui s'imposaient pour freiner
la flambée épidémique le retour du
masque en extérieur et la fermeture des
bars et des restaurants à compter de 23h
vous le savez il existe toujours un
décalage entre l'augmentation du nombre
de cas et l'augmentation du nombre
d'admissions à l'hôpital par ailleurs et
heureusement la vaccination limite
sensiblement le nombre de formes graves
mais la couverture vaccinale reste
insuffisante dans notre pays à l'heure
actuelle on peut constater que les
hospitalisations sont repartis à la
hausse certes en partant d'un niveau
très bas mais à la hausse quand même +
43 % des admissions à l'hôpital et + 27%
d'admission en réanimation en une
semaine en espagne ou au portugal les
états réinstaure des couvre-feux referme
des établissements partout en europe
le pass sanitaires se déploie certains
prenant des libertés avec les faits
veulent faire du pass sanitaire une
exception française
il n'en est rien en allemagne au
portugal en autriche au danemark en
grèce en irlande le pass sanitaire a été
mis en place où a été décidée sera mis
prochainement en place
le point commun entre ces pays européens
et que nous sommes tous des démocraties
libérales
face à une situation hôtel nous devions
réagir réagir pour que l'hôpital ne soit
pas submergés par la quatrième vague
c'est le sens même des décisions prises
par le président de la république la
semaine dernière ce soir le conseil des
ministres a adopté le projet de loi
portant adaptation de nos outils de
gestion de la crise sanitaire
il concrétise cette volonté du président
de la république avec des mesures
nouvelles
des mesures fortes les mesures fermes
visant la vaccination générale notamment
nous les assumons nous assumons de
prendre des mesures inédites parce que
cette crise est inédite et que notre
volonté de vivre appelle des solutions
nouvelles
nous assumons d'avancé parce que nous
refusons que tous nos concitoyens soit
amené à payer pour l'attentisme parfois
le cynisme de temps en temps et plus
de manière plus isolé l'égoïsme de
certains
présentement comme les restaurants et
les bars qui verront l'application du
pas salutaire à compter du début du mois
d'août
une autre mesure ayant prouvé son
efficacité était tendue par cette loi
elle prévoit en effet le placement
obligatoire à l'isolément pour une durée
de dix jours de toute personne testée
positive cette mesure existait déjà pour
les personnes rentrant de l'étranger
d'une liste de pays rouges avec un
contrôle de police et des amendes
possibles des verbalisations jusqu'à
1000 euros
l'étendre à toutes les personnes
positives susceptibles d'en contaminer
je le rappelle avec le variant delta en
moyenne cinq ou six d'autres relèvent du
bon sens un encadrement par le juge des
libertés est évidemment prévu dans ce
texte
nous prenons donc les devants pour
prévenir au maximum les contaminations
lorsque ce danger est immédiat qui
concerne des personnes fragiles nous le
prévenant avec d'autant plus de fermeté
c'est le sens de l'obligation vaccinale
que cette loi prévoit pour l'ensemble
des personnels au contact régulier des
publics fragiles là encore c'est une
extension d'une mesure qui existe déjà
pour l'hépatite b pour le tétanos ou
encore pour la diphtérie l'obligation
concernera l'ensemble des personnels de
santé ainsi que les personnels
intervenant au domicile des personnes
fragiles elle s'applique également aux
personnels des services d'incendié et de
secours aux membres des associations
agréées de sécurité civile ainsi qu'aux
personnes exerçant des activités de
transport sanitaire
toutes ces personnes devront donc être
doublement vacciner au 15 septembre
prochain enfin nous l'avons toujours dit
nous souhaitons rendre le vaccin le plus
simple le plus accessible possible pour
tous les français c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'article 6 de ce projet de loi
prévoit une autorisation d'absence sans
baisse de rémunération pour les salariés
qui souhaitent se faire vacciner sur
leur temps de travail
je tiens à souligner le caractère
temporaire de ces mesures
le pass and i ter ne sera par exemple
nécessaire que si longtemps que le virus
pourra menacer les personnes regroupées
nous l'avons dit depuis le premier jour
nous ne reculerons jamais devant une
mesure efficace pour protéger les
français mais nous n'imposerons jamais
qu'ils soient strictement qu'ils ne
soient strictement nécessaire ce projet
de loi sera examiné dès cette semaine au
parlement
on allait vite ne laissant aucune chance
au virus je sais que le pass sanitaire
provoque chez certains professionnels
des interrogations voire des craintes je
les dis bien un instant pour la mise en
oeuvre opérationnelle et j'ai donc
annoncé cette période de rodage qui
interviendra dans un premier temps il ya
aussi des craintes sur le chiffre
d'affaires et je veux ici leur dire
droit dans les yeux évidemment que les
aides continueront à s'appliquer et que
nous ferons du sur mesure
ce qui me permet de rappeler
qu'aujourd'hui même le fonds de
solidarité ouvre pour le mois de juin
chacun peut s'inscrire chacun peut
d'autant plus inscrire que nous avons
élargi le fonds de solidarité qui
concerne désormais tous les commerces
quelles que soient les pertes par
rapport à 2019 alors je leur dis si vous
avez des pertes de votre chiffre
d'affaires par rapport au mois de juin
inscrivez vous dès aujourd'hui au fonds
de solidarité vous pourrez recevoir une
aide correspondant à une partie de la
perte que vous avez subie par rapport à
votre chiffre d'affaires de 2019
mais au delà des professionnels plus
largement face à cette situation
je comprends le désarroi l'exaspération
face à une épidémie qui fourre dans
notre pays depuis près de 18 mois
nous avons fait tant d'efforts pour
sortir de cette épidémie nous avons
consenti beaucoup de restrictions depuis
un an et demi les français ont été
exceptionnels et rien ni personne ne
devra nous le faire oublier
aujourd'hui la donne a changé avec le
vaccin nous pouvons reprendre la main
sur le virus nous ne céderons pas à la
dictature des images choquantes des
slogans outrancier des raccourcis
honteux la majorité des français la
grande majorité des français c'est déjà
fait vacciner ou a pris rendez vous pour
se faire vacciner
37 millions de personnes ont reçu au
moins une injection de vaccin
près de sept majeur sur 10 ont déjà reçu
une dose plus de 4 millions de rendez
vous ont été pris depuis l'intervention
du président de la république
la semaine dernière les faits sont là
les français se vaccine les français
sont responsables ne nous laissons pas
distraire de cette vision d'ensemble par
une infime minorité
nous devons aller plus loin encore nous
avons les doses nécessaires
nous en avions 1 9 million en stocks en
début de la semaine dernière quand le
président de la république s'est exprimé
et nous en recevrons près de quatre
millions et demi par semaine tout au
long du mois d'août il y à une
mobilisation générale pour un été va
finale nous faisons tout pour renforcer
les centres de vaccination et je veux
ici lancé un appel à tous les bénévoles
à tous les soignants en consacrant
quelques heures que vous avez deux
disponibles de votre temps en août à la
vaccination vous continuerez à être des
combattants de l'immunité collective les
artisans de la sortie définitive de
cette crise manifestez vous si vous êtes
disponible auprès des centres de
vaccination je rappelle par ailleurs que
la liste des personnels de santé qui
peuvent vacciner a été étendu la semaine
dernière par olivier ferrand et que
peuvent désormais vacciner une liste de
professions qui jusqu'à présent ne le
pouvaient pas je pense au kiné je pense
aux orthophonistes ou diététicien qui
peuvent vacciner dans les centres je
veux dire aussi que le président de la
république a souhaité que à l'occasion
de cet été là l'organisation de notre
campagne de vaccination soutiennent
encore davantage les pharmaciens dans
leur rôle dans la campagne de
vaccination ils sont un maillon
absolument essentiel il ya par ailleurs
un maillage officinal dans notre pays
qui est extrêmement dense qu'il ya des
pharmacies partout et notamment sur les
zones de vacances et donc nous allons
continuer à soutenir les soutenir encore
davantage les pharmaciens pour qu'ils
puissent participer pleinement avec les
doses nécessaires à la campagne de
vaccination je veux dire aussi que nous
faisons parfaitement la différence entre
ceux qui ont des doutes sincère sur le
vaccin et ceux qui manipulent les peurs
dans le seul objectif de connaître une
gloire médiatique ou de mener un combat
politicien oui il ya des français qui
doute oui il ya des français qui se
posent des questions régulièrement je
suis interrogée notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux ou à l'occasion de
déplacements par des personnes qui se
pose sincèrement des questions sur le
vaccin et ses effets et je veux profiter
de ce compte rendu pour répondre ici à
trois questions qui reviennent
régulièrement
la première c'est ce qui me demande si
le vaccin sert vraiment à quelque chose
pour eux parce qu'ils sont jeunes parce
qu'ils ont peu de chance peu de risque
de faire des formes graves et que les
personnes fragiles autour d'eux sont
déjà vaccinés
c'est vrai peu de jeunes développent des
symptômes fort mais un certain nombre en
revanche subissent les effets d'échos
vie de long et vivent avec des symptômes
pendant des semaines voire des mois
je pense à des fatigue extrême ou à la
perte durable du goût et de l'odorat et
surtout si vous faites vacciner pour
permettait de limiter
la transmission du virus et la
circulation du virus dans notre pays or
nous savons qu'un virus mute quand il
circule largement et donc si nous
laissions le virus circule est largement
dans la population
quand bien même cette population serait
jeunes et auraient moins de risques avec
la souche actuelle du virus de faire une
forme grave
il y aurait le risque que demain
apparaissent invariants capa ou
haussiers rare puisque c'est l'alphabet
aéronautique qui est maintenant utilisée
et qui pourrait entraîner des formes
graves pour une population plus jeune et
nous avons déjà vu dans l'histoire des
épidémies ou des virus
touché en premier lieu des personnes
âgées ou des personnes fragiles et puis
à l'occasion de vagues ultérieures
touchaient des populations plus jeunes
la seconde crainte qui me revient
régulièrement c'est que ce vaccin aurait
été mis au point
trop rapidement dans son application
vaccinale il a certes été mis au point
rapidement mais la rn et ce message et
n'est pas une technologie nouvelle
elle a été découverte il ya 60 ans et
les recherches pour l'utiliser dans le
cadre de traitement avait commencé il ya
des années la crise a permis d'investir
des milliards pour la recherche de faire
aboutir les travaux scientifiques
mais le développement du vaccin en
respectant scrupuleusement toutes les
étapes de validation imposé à chaque
vaccin a été respectée par ailleurs les
scientifiques ce n'est pas moi ici qui
le dit mais les scientifiques
indépendants qui s'exprime régulièrement
dans les médias au contact de leurs
patients le disent les principaux effets
secondaires liés à un vaccin ou un
médicament surviennent quasi toujours
dans les six premiers mois après
l'utilisation
or cela fait bien plus de six mois et
nous avons bien plus de six mois de
recul sur ce vaccin les premières
personnes ayant reçu une dose dans le
cadre des essais cliniques ont reçu leur
injection il ya un an et nous
l'observons le seul effet massif du
vaccin aujourd'hui c'est qu'il protège
qu'il protège des formes graves et
qu'ils limitent dans une certaine mesure
la transmission du virus et dernière
interpellation que je reçois souvent
justement le vaccin serait inutile parce
qu'il n'empêcherait ni d'être contaminés
ni d'eau contaminée il faut regarder la
les faits scientifiques en face
oui il est toujours possible d'être
contaminé en étant vacciner mais on
risque beaucoup moins de lettres une
personne vaccinée et protéger je le
disais
instant à 95% contre les formes graves
et elle a douze fois moins de risque de
transmettre le virus là aussi ce sont
des études scientifiques indépendantes
qui en attestent
alors vaccinant nous protégeons-nous et
protégeant les autres évitons que cette
quatrième vague emporte tout sur son
passage
mesdames et messieurs le président de la
république l'a rappelé cette situation
sanitaire ne doit pas freiner notre
action notre volonté indéfectible de
réformes et de transformation et ce
conseil des ministres a été l'occasion
d'adopter un certain nombre de textes
importants
tout d'abord le ministre de l'intérieur
et le garde des sceaux ont présenté un
projet de loi relatif à la
responsabilité pénale et à la sécurité
intérieure
ce projet marque une nouvelle étape dans
notre action résolue pour la sécurité
des français
il fait écho à l'indignation provoquée à
la suite de la faire sarah halimi il est
aussi la mise en oeuvre concrète
pratique les engagements pris devant les
policiers pour renforcer leur protection
à la suite du terrible meurtre d'éric
masson à avignon la protection des
forces de l'ordre beaucoup en ont parlé
nous agissons nous sommes fidèles à nos
promesses car nous croyons que
l'engagement des forces de l'ordre est
exceptionnelle et que tous ceux qui les
attaquent doivent être sanctionnée avec
la plus totale
ces vérités sur le plan judiciaire ce
projet de loi fait évoluer la loi pour
mettre fin à certains cas d'
irresponsabilité pénale qui ne se
justifiait plus la loi exclut ainsi
l'irresponsabilité pénale lorsque la
personne a volontairement consommé des
substances psycho actives dans le
dessein de commettre une infraction
elle crée aussi de nouvelles infractions
qui permettront de réprimer sévèrement
la consommation volontaire de substance
lorsque celle ci aura des conséquences
violentes ou meurtrière sur le plan de
la protection de nos forces de l'ordre
ce texte instaure un délit spécifique
plus sévère de violences volontaires
commises à l'encontre des policiers des
gendarmes et plus largement encore de
tous les militaires les consignes des
policiers des gendarmes ne sont pas
négociables
aussi ce texte durcit le régime du refus
d'obtempérer
enfin pour accroître ses capacités
opérationnelles et renforcer ses liens
avec la population
la réserve civile de la police nationale
sera transformé en réserve
opérationnelle
je tiens à rappeler que ces diverses
mesures s'inscrivent dans un contexte de
hausse continue des moyens
de la police comme de la justice qui se
traduit par des moyens financiers des
moyens matériels supplémentaires depuis
le début de ce quinquennat
des moyens qui sont historiques et qui
continuera à s'appliquer évidemment
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat
sur un autre sujet je vous présentais il
y a deux semaines
nos mesures de revalorisation salariale
à destination des agents publics
notamment aux moins favorisés
la ministre de la transformation et de
la fonction publique a présenté
aujourd'hui un projet de loi ratifiant
une ordonnance relative à la formation
de ses agents par cette ordonnance nous
poursuivons notre mobilisation pour
l'égalité pour la valorisation de
l'ensemble des acteurs du service public
l'accès à la formation de ses agents et
notamment des moins qualifiés sera
facilitée et renforcé ils bénéficieront
en effet de droits supplémentaires et de
congés adapté pour y accéder nous avons
également adopté trois ordonnances
la ministre de la transition écologique
a présenté une ordonnance modifiant le
produit équipements à risque du code de
l'environnement
cette ordonnance va permettre des
mesures de surveillance renforcée pour
garantir la conformité de nombreux
produits à risques nous avons ensuite
adopté une ordonnance transposant une
directive européenne qui facilite les
échanges d'informations financières pour
lutter contre certaines infractions
pénales
les échanges accrus entre les services
de police judiciaire les services de
renseignement traque fin de bercy
--l'agence europol permettront de mieux
lutter contre l'ensemble de la crim de
la criminalité organisée et financière
c'est là un pas important pour
l'intégration européenne des capacités
d'enquêté et de répression est donc très
concrètement pour l'europe de la
sécurité enfin le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé a présenté
une ordonnance qui instaure comme prévu
par la loi santé de 2019
une certification périodique de certains
professionnels de santé notre idée est
simple définir un cadre juridique clair
pour permettre à échéances régulières de
maintenir les compétences et les
connaissances partout sur le territoire
voilà mesdames et messieurs ce que je
pouvais vous dire sur le conseil des
ministres de ce lundi
je me tiens à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions bonjour
monsieur le ministre agathe tomberait
pour bfm tv
vous avez évoqué les centres commerciaux
dans les lieux qu'ils seraient
couvert par le passé ni terre est ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus parce que
le conseil d'état lui a exclu en tout
cas dans son avis les centres
commerciaux des établissements concernés
enfin j'aimerais avoir des précisions si
c'est possible sur les amendes en cas
d'isolement par exemple en cas de
non-respect de l'isolément de 10 jours
qu'elle sera l'amendé encourue pour les
citoyens et qu'elle sera l'amendé
encourue pour les professionnels qui ne
feront pas respecté les règles du passé
ni terre là aussi le conseil d'état a
émis une réserve la barre était placée
très haut à la base d'accords alors sur
le premier point sur les centres
commerciaux effectivement le conseil
d'état à 10 juin la mesure qui prévoyait
l'application du pass sanitaires aux
centres commerciaux ils à 10 juin pour
une raison évoquée qui était le risque
que cela empêche des français d'accéder
à des biens de première nécessité
c'est à dire des biens notamment
alimentaires nous avons donc décidé de
d'adapter la rédaction de cette mesure
dans le projet de loi qui a été adopté
concrètement l'article dans le projet de
loi prévoit bien l'extension du pass
sanitaires pour les centres commerciaux
dont la superficie excède un seuil qui
sera défini par décret et il prévoit de
manière écrite dans l'article que lequel
le pass pourra être requis dans les
centres commerciaux
dès lors que sera garantit l'accès des
personnes aux biens et aux produits de
première nécessité notamment
alimentaires à l'échelle du territoire
très concrètement ça veut dire que si à
l'échelle du territoire où se trouve le
centre commercial du bassin de vie il y
à des commerces qui ne sont pas dans le
centre commercial mais qui permettre de
s'acheter des produits de premières
nécessités alimentaires ou
pharmaceutiques alors le pass sanitaire
pourra s'appliquer dans le centre
commercial de ce même bassin de vie
sur le deuxième point que vous avez
évoqué sur la question des amendes il me
semble sur les allemandes pour le
non-respect de l' isolement que c'est le
régime qui existent déjà aujourd'hui
pour les personnes qui viennent de pays
rouges et qui doivent avoir un isolement
obligatoire qui s'applique donc c'est le
même cadre de sanctions sur les amendes
pour ce qui est de la non utilisation du
pass sanitaires
dans les lieux où il est requis d'abord
je veux rappeler ce que je vous ai dit
il ya un instant c'est que notre premier
objectif c'est évidemment d'accompagner
les professionnels qui sont concernés
qu'il y aura une période de rodage dans
un premier temps qui permettra plutôt
que des contrôles et des verbalisations
des sanctions d'avoir de
l'accompagnement dans l'utilisation de
l'outil et dans le déploiement du pass
sanitaire dans ces lieux ça commence dès
ce mercredi pour les lieux culturels ou
les lieux de loisirs et puis à partir du
début du mois d'août pour les autres
lieux qui sont visés par le pass
sanitaire ensuite évidemment qu'il faut
un cadre de sanctions
et d'ailleurs je vais vous dire il est
régulièrement demandée par les
professionnels eux-mêmes qu'ils nous
disent régulièrement qu'il n'y a rien de
pire que de devoir appliquer une règle
qui s'apparente quand même à une
certaine contrainte parce que ça demande
une organisation si on a le sentiment
que notre collègue qui a la même
activité que nous à l'autre bout de la
rue ou un peu plus loin n'appliquent pas
les règles parce qu'il n'y a pas de
contrôle et de sanction donc oui à
partir d'un moment il y aura des
contrôles et des sanctions pour ce qui
est des amendes
c'est vrai que dans un premier temps
dans le texte que nous avons transmis au
conseil d'état
il était prévu que dès la première
infraction constatée
cela relève du délit avec du coup une
peine pouvant aller jusqu'à un an
d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros d'amande
et ce qui est prévu dans le projet de
loi qui a été adopté en conseil des
ministres parce que nous sommes
pragmatiques
parce que nous avons échangé aussi avec
les représentants des différents
secteurs professionnels
c'est un système qui est davantage
progressif donc très concrètement ça
commence par une contravention de
cinquième classe
donc c'est jusqu'à 1500 euros pour une
personne physique et 7500 euros pour une
personne morale et à la troisième
réitération
cela passe à un délit qui peut aller
jusqu'à un an et 9000 euros d'amendé
pour une personne physique un an et
45000 euros d'amendé pour une personne
morale
bonsoir jeudi marie lecomte france info
vous nous disiez que en fonction de la
situation géographique des centres
commerciaux
selon qu'on puisse ou non accéder à des
biens de première nécessité dans un
rayon
raisonnable à l'échelle du bassin
ça c'est une décision qui appartiendra
au préfet de dire dans tel centre
commercial je demande l'application du
sens du passé ni terre évidemment qu'on
fera en lien avec les préfets les élus
locaux qui connaissent parfaitement la
réalité des différents territoires
je veux rappeler par ailleurs que pour
la piste de travail sur laquelle nous
avançons maintenant avec les
professionnels c'est-à-dire des centres
commerciaux de plus de 20 mille mètres
carrés cela concerne il me semble 300 ou
400 centres commerciaux en france dont
nous aurons la possibilité d'apprécier
les choses selon des modalités qui
seront définies rapidement par bruno le
maire
j'ai peut-être malentendus mais vous
avez prononcé la date du 30 août au
début de votre intervention
je ne sais pas si votre langue a fourché
on est bien d'accord que toutes les
mesures entrent en vigueur le 1er août
oui je parlais de l'entrée en vigueur du
pacte sanitaires pour les salariés des
lieux où il est exigé d'accord en ce qui
concerne en ce qui concerne le temps de
rodage
vous savez d'ores et déjà de combien de
temps il sera une semaine deux semaines
non il durera le temps nécessaire
c'est à dire qu'on va regarder
concrètement comment les choses se
mettent en place
il faudra de temps suffisant pour avoir
un retour d'expérience sur la manière
dont le pass sanitaire est utilisé sur
d'éventuelles freins qui existeraient
qui nous permettra d'adapter les choses
mais il y aura donc ce temps qui nous
permettra encore une fois d'accompagner
les professionnels il ya absolument
aucune envie de piéger personne d'abord
au départ si on pouvait se passer du
pass sanitaire si on pouvait se passer
de toutes ces mesures on s'en passerait
volontiers
il ya un virus dans notre pays qui est
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus dangereux
qu'il ne l'était auparavant parce qu'il
est beaucoup plus contaminateur et donc
il nous faut prendre des mesures mais
ces mesures ne visent pas à piéger qui
que ce soit ne vise pas à considérer que
qui que ce soit et un criminel ou un
fraudeur
elle vise à faire en sorte qu'on puisse
maintenir un cadre qui nous permet
d'accéder à des lieux de vie sociale qui
nous permet de continuer à nous voir à
nous retrouver tout en limitant au
maximum la circulation du virus dans
notre pays pour ne pas avoir à tour
fermé comme malheureusement nous l'avons
connu déjà dans notre pays donc la date
légale d'un train vigueur c'est bien le
1er août la date de la date d légal
d'entrée en vigueur du pasteur c'est une
mercredi pour les lieux de loisirs et
culturelles et début août je peux pas
vous donner le jour le jour précis
puisque ça dépendra de la date de la
promulgation du texte de loi mais on a
toujours dit début août pour les autres
lieux vous avez parlé une mesure
temporaire
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya ce
qu'on appelle une clause de revoyure
c'est à dire c'était mesures qui sont
mises en place pendant un certain temps
où jusqu'à la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
ça veut dire que le régime transitoire
de sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
est prolongé jusqu'à la fin de l'année
et que donc les mesures sont prévues
dans ce cadre
évidemment il y aura des rendez vous
réguliers avec le parlement pour faire
le point avec eux sur ces mesures
mais donc là on pèse sur pc ni terre est
tendue au moins jusqu'au 31 décembre
j'ai dit dans mon intervention autant
que ce sera nécessaire pour limiter la
circulation du virus dans des lieux qui
brassent un certain nombre de personnes
bonjour line is gone de blogueurs se
désole c'est un peu la même question que
ma confrères mais de fait du fait de
cette période de rodage
quand est-ce que vous pensez que
l'application effective dans les fêtes
l'upa sanitaire pourra débuter vraiment
mais je vous dis que le passe à 8 heures
il entre en vigueur
aux termes du décret qui a été pris pour
les lieux culture et les loisirs à
partir de mercredi et qu'il rentre en
vigueur qu'il rentrera en vigueur pour
les restaurants les bars les autres
lieux à partir de début août quand la
loi sera promulguée
au départ j'ai dit qu'il y avait un
premier temps de rodage vous ne vous ai
pas dit combien de temps il dure elle
sera quand même voilà doit pas durer un
mois
il sera assez limité je sais pas ce sera
une semaine un peu plus mais encore une
fois il faut pas considérer du coup que
ça reporte la date d'entrée en vigueur
du pass sanitaire le pas salutaire entre
vigueur aux dates qui sont prévues
simplement au départ les forces de
sécurité qui sont mobilisées pour faire
les contrôles de l'application du pass
sanitaire le ferons non pas pour
contrôler et verbaliser les personnes
qui ne fera pas mais pour les aider les
accompagner dans utilisation du pass une
autre question sur les mesures prises
par le royaume uni à l'encontre en tout
cas qui affecte les voyageurs venant de
france qui sont désormais soumis une
quarantaine là bas même s'ils sont
vaccinés ce matin le secrétaire d'état
aux affaires européennes clément bonne
suggérait qu'il s'agissait de la part du
royaume uni d'une décision qui était
plus politique que scientifique
est ce que la france pourrait prendre
des mesures similaires à l'encontre des
voyageurs qui viennent de royaume uni ou
toutes autres mesures de réponse
cette à cette décision britannique alors
je vous confiant que la décision qui a
été prise par les autorités britanniques
d'imposer cette quarantaine obligatoire
aux ressortissants français n'est pas
prise sur des considérations sanitaires
mais sur des considérations politiques
et qu'elle est à notre sens excessive ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que nous
échangeons avec les autorités
britanniques
aujourd'hui j'ai pas de mesures de
réciprocité à vous annoncer aujourd'hui
mais évidemment nous ne fermons
absolument aucune porte à la matière
mais nous échangeons avec elle
aujourd'hui nous sommes à ce stade-là de
ce dossier
le téléphone du président de la
république at il été compromis par
pegasus est un assaut mois sur ce sujet
à pegasus qui est un sujet grave je
dispose des informations qui ont été
diffusées dans la presse avec une
enquête internationale qui a été menée
par des journalistes
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire ce matin
que si ces faits sont avérés ils sont
très graves
on attends tu en train actuellement de
regarder ce dossier attentivement je
peux pas vous dire autre chose que cela
la presse rapporte que trois chefs
d'états européens ont été affectés et
donc quand vous dites on regarde ce
sujet attentivement c'est à dire qu'en
ce moment les téléphones du présidentmd
sont en train de sont soumis à un fort
mc cloud pour vérifier que qu' ils ne
sont pas infectés j'ai bien compris ça
veut dire que nous regardons ce sujet de
très près merci merci beaucoup
ah non c'était pas une question bonjour
mélanie cousin pour tf1 j'ai une petite
précision par rapport aux centres
commerciaux
quand dans les bassins de vie il n'y a
pas de magasin de première nécessité
dans ce cas là il y aura pas de contrôle
dans ses centres commerciaux vous
comment ça va se passer si on ne peut
garantir l'accès à des biens de première
nécessité c'est à dire principalement
alimentaire ou pharmaceutique à
l'échelle d'un bassin de vie que dans ce
bassin de vie ces biens ne sont
accessibles que dans un grand centre
commercial
il n'y aura pas d' utilisation du pass
sanitaire dans ce centre commercial
c'est ça que ça veut dire d'accord même
dans les magasins dhabi par exemple
d'habillement de décoration bas priori
l'utilisation du passé ni terre se fait
à l'échelle du centre commercial je
disais tout à l'heure c'était 300 ou 400
centres commerciaux concernés mais je
crois que cette trente mille boutique à
l'intérieur donc le faire à l'échec à
l'échelle de chaque boutique
je crois que ça serait compliqué et j'ai
une telle application par rapport à l'
isolement
est-ce que vous avez déjà prévu de
mettre des policiers combien de
policiers seront en place pour contrôler
ses idoles je peux pas vous annoncer un
chiffre ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya déjà un isolement
obligatoire contrôlée par nos forces de
sécurité et verbaliser avec des amendes
importantes qui existe pour les
personnes qui rejoignent la france
venant d'une liste de pays rouges est à
dire les pays les plus à risques
vis-à-vis de la circulation du virus ou
de variants dangereux d'abord je précise
qu'ils sont très peu nombreux à
rejoindre la france parce qu'il ya des
motifs impérieux et que les choses sont
extrêmement encadrées il faut être
français il faut avoir un motif
impérieux pour venir en france et dans
ces cas là il ya des contrôles qui sont
quasiment systématique ils sont
aléatoires on prévient pas de l'heure du
contrôle et donne lieu à des
verbalisations et donc il ya des forces
de sécurité suffisante pour effectuer
ces contrôles là où ils existent déjà et
il y en aura pour effectuer des
contrôles là où ils existent au
rendement
si le parlement évidemment adopte cette
mesure est une dernière question
pardonnez moi si vous avez déjà répondu
mais il me semble pas sur l'isolément
des personnes positives le conseil
d'état des conseils
les contrôles nocturnes la nuit allait
contrôler domicile par les forces de
l'ordre
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose que
vous à les exclure
est-ce que vous allez suivre cet avis ou
est-ce que vous vous maintenez
effectivement il ya une remarque qui a
été fait par le conseil d'état sur ce
sujet là est ce qui est prévu dans le
projet de loi c'est que les contrôles
peuvent s'effectuer jusqu'à 23h donc pas
entre 23 heures et 8 heures du matin
c'est d'autres demandes de détails
d'autres questions je suis à la
disposition sinon je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine on retrouve nos mercredi cette
fois ci la semaine prochaine
à